I've been taking two capsules of Phase 2 colon support, and for those that don't know, Phase 2 colon support has some triophia triophila in it, but the biggest thing in it, that's to help heal the colon has magnesium in it for bowel movements aid, and then it has some Cape Aloe in it.
For those who are not familiar with Cape Aloe, Cape Aloe is a great supplement. Don't confuse it with Aloe products that are healing to the gut, or Aloe products that are immune stimulators, or Aloe products that are cancer fighters.
Cape Aloe is a type of product that will help you with bowel movements. This has also Cape Aloe in it, hence the Phase 6 colon support. Phase 6 has to do with your moving your bowel, so Phase 6 refers to the detoxification pathway.
This product is actually one of our private table products, that's why we use Phase 6 out there. So Phase 6, if you're not familiar with our 7 phases of detoxification, Phase 6 is the phase of detoxification where you're getting it destroyed.
So Phase 6 colon support has 50 milligrams of the Cape Aloe in it. Now, honestly, and I think that's per two capsules, too. So, honestly, that's not very much Cape Aloe.
We have another product, I think it's called Phase 6 assist, and that has 250 milligrams of Cape Aloe. So a big difference there, right?
So if a person is really constipated at having issues, we typically recommend that Phase 6 assist, which has a much higher amount of Cape Aloe. It's not really anything else but the Cape Aloe.
But that is really going to help a person move their balls, but let me get to this person's question.
I've been taking two capsules in the Phase 6 colon support every night at bedtime for almost two weeks. I'm not quite as constipated though.
The M's have are more frequent than in the last few days that have increased in size a bit, but are still not back to normal.
Should I give it more time or increase the dosage my water take is 70 to 90 ounces a day.
So, no, there's, so when a person has constipation issues, maybe their first go to should be, should be magnesium.
So, that's what people are most familiar with. So you take excess magnesium, you can't really take too much magnesium because you'll just dump that magnesium in the bowl.
But what that will do is it will draw water to the ball, and it will typically loosen up your stools.
So, taking way too much magnesium is good, you're going to really do the stools, you're going to watch that.
It doesn't always work with everybody. So, then using something like Cape Allo can be your next best bet.
So, taking Cape Allo can help get you regulated. Again, this particular product, the Phase 6 colon support, is a much lower dose of Cape Allo.
So, I would just up the dosage till you feel like you're more regular, and then you could lower the dosage down.
But, again, for people who have really bad constipation issues, or just have, once in a while they have bad constipation issues, using the Phase 6 assist, which is the higher dosage of Cape Allo, and just doing that once in a while can be a better choice.
The Phase 6 colon support is more for long-term use, it can be healing to the colon as well, and it's not so much about mover as it is the other dose, the higher dose of Cape Allo.